das zentrum unserer galaxie wird sich
entzünden
ihr durchmesser beträgt unglaubliche 100
tausend lichtjahre
und sie ist unsere galaktischer heimat
die milchstraße die galaxie also in der
wir leben
dennoch haben fachleute sie noch längst
nicht im detail verstanden ein us
forschungsteam hat jetzt im zentrum der
milchstraße eine überraschende
entdeckung gemacht demnach wird das
zentrum unserer galaxie sich zu einem
der hellsten objekte im universum
entzünden klicks dem sunset future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen klicks
und gibt es übrigens auch auf die ohren
als podcast der link ist hier unter me
und spotify level podcast in der video
beschreibung in diesem video geht es um
eines der wohl spannendsten rätsel der
milchstraße die sich aus bis zu 200
milliarden sternen zusammen setzt mit
ihrem durchmesser von etwa hundert
tausend lichtern ist unsere heimat
galaxie wirklich riesig und
forschungsteams weltweit stoßen immer
wieder auf neue spannende erkenntnisse
so auch jetzt ein us forschungsteam hat
im inneren der milchstraße einen
überschuss an schwach ionisiertes gas
aufgespürt und das ist ein hinweis
darauf dass die milchstraße
möglicherweise eine ganz andere galaxie
ist als wir bislang gedacht hatten was
bedeutet dieses sogenannte linear signal
im herzen der milchstraße und wie kommt
es überhaupt zustande dass wells
astronomie team hatte für seine studie
eine äußerst umfangreiche auswertung
vorgenommen im visier hatten die
forschenden die daten des schalkers wenn
dieses teleskop der universität
wisconsin ist darauf ausgelegt das
optische lichtspektrum aus dem
innenbereich der milchstraße einzufangen
und diese analyse offenbart ein äußerst
überraschendes ergebnis im herzen der
milchstraße wurde ein verräterisches
signal aufgespürt es handelt sich um das
sogenannte lina signal die abkürzung
steht für low ionisation lukla im
mission leyen region übersetzt also etwa
so viel wie eine emission region im kern
einer aktiven galaxie die geringe uni
sieht
das ist also das kennzeichen aller
linear galaxien ein besonders hoher
anteil schwach ionisierte gase in ihrem
inneren bereich solche lineas zeichnen
sich weiterhin dadurch aus dass sie eine
geringe kern läuft kraft haben im
spektrum sind lediglich schmale aber
keine breiten emissions- linien zu
beobachten diese galaxie typen und jetzt
wird es interessant gelten als
übergangsform zwischen den eher
inaktiven ruhigen galaxien und den
aktiven galaxienkernen wie den basaren
in unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft sind
rund ein drittel der galaxien sogenannte
linear galaxien auch andromeda also
unseren nachbarn galaxie gehört dazu
erst vor kurzem hatte ein anderes us
forschungsteam sogenannte transformer
galaxien aufgespürt die sich abrupt von
einer linea galaxie zu einem quasi
gewandelt hatten die fachleute hatten
insgesamt sechs dieser zwischen galaxien
über neun monate hinweg genauer im
visier zunächst verhielten sich die
galaxien unauffällig und normal dann
aber leuchteten sie auf und das ganz
plötzlich überraschender weise ließ
dieses leuchten auch nicht mehr nach und
zudem leuchteten auch die weiteren fünf
galaxien hellauf dass das zentrale
schwarze loch eine kurze mahlzeit
verspeiste und der strahlend ausbruch
damit zu erklären war schied also aus
denn dafür leuchteten die galaxien viel
zu lange auf stattdessen hatten sich die
galaxien wohl innerhalb von sehr kurzer
zeit in quasare umgewandelt dazu eine
der beteiligten forscherinnen sarah
vorweg wir stellten fest dass ein zuvor
ruhendes schwarzes loch eine
transformation durch machte die
astronomen changing look nennen das
ergebnis ist ein heller quasi das
bestätigt dass linie galaxien sehr wohl
aktive supermassereiche schwarze löcher
in ihrem zentrum haben können
überraschend für die fachleute war vor
allem dass dies innerhalb eines sehr
kurzen zeitraumes passierte sie sprechen
von einer zitat plötzlichen und
dramatischen transformation dabei ging
man lange zeit davon aus dass quasare
mehrere tausend jahre brauchen um sich
zu entwickeln diese theorie wurde durch
die us studie allerdings komplett auf
den kopf gestellt dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam in seiner studie
es ist sehr überraschend dass eine
galaxie aussehen innerhalb menschlicher
zeit massstäbe ändern kann
in dieser studie aus dem vergangenen
jahr 2009 10 konnte also an
völlig neue klasse aktive galaxienkerne
identifiziert wenn sechs relativ ruhige
lena galaxien zeigten einen abrupten
übergang zum quasi der mechanismus der
dahinter steckt ist allerdings noch
immer unbekannt und weitere forschung
ist notwendig um dahinter zu kommen dazu
die astronomen sarah frederik es wird
einiges an arbeit erfordern um zu
verstehen was solche veränderungen in so
kurzer zeit hervorrufen kann
hier müssen extreme und sehr starke
kräfte am werk sein und genau diese
kräfte werden dann in extrem kurzer zeit
das zentrum unserer eigenen galaxie im
wahrsten sinne des wortes entzünden
das muss wirklich von der erde aus ein
dramatischer anblick sein wenn es nicht
schon passiert ist immerhin ist das
zentrum 25 tausend lichtjahre von uns
entfernt und das ist nicht das einzige
mysteriöse rätsel forschungsteams
weltweit fragen sich auch was genau
galaxien zu linearen werden lässt und
wie sich die ionisierten gasströme
erklären lassen auch die vorstellung aus
wisconsin waren dieser frage auf der
spur möglicherweise enthalten die
zentren dieser galaxien ein prozess der
gase immer wieder auf ein neues zum
ionisieren bringt in der chemie meint
die organisation denjenigen vorgang bei
dem ein atom oder molekül elektronen
entzogen werden dadurch bleiben die
ursprünglichen atome oder moleküle als
positiv geladenes ion zurück dazu max
häfner der an der university wyss
konsumforscher ohne eine anhaltende
energiezufuhr re kombinieren sich
millionen und freien elektronen schnell
wieder und kehren zu ihrem neutralen
zustand zurück doch wie kann man sich
solch eine energiezufuhr vorstellen die
also dieses ständige ionisieren immer
wieder hervorruft und was ist ihre
ursache werden die auffälligen ihre
organisations signale durch eine
besonders starke stern bildung innerhalb
der galaxie verursacht manche fachleute
sehen dies als erklärung für die
mysteriöse energiezufuhr in den linear
galaxien andere astronomie teams dagegen
erklären dies mit den aktiven
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern in
den zentren der galaxien
doch das nun aufgespürte linie signal
steht das alles noch mal ganz neu auf
den kopf denn die aktuelle analyse des
us-teams offenbart ganz eindeutig dass
auch im zentrum unserer milchstraße ein
überschuss an schwache ionisierten gasen
existiert diese bilden eine art scheibe
die um etwa fünf grad gegen die galaxien
ebene geneigt ist dort ein teil
sind atomare gase die achtung um mehr
als 50% ionisiert sind dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam die optischen linien
verhältnisse dieser gase unterscheiden
sich von allen anderen in der
milchstraße aber sie sind typisch für
die emission von den eher galaxien vor
dieser entdeckung war die millionen
lichtjahre entfernte andromeda galaxie
der uns nächsten er die forscher sind
sich also sehr sicher dass auch unsere
galaktische heimat die milchstraße eine
linie galaxie ist in der studie heißt es
angesichts der tatsache dass lina gase
besonders häufig bei galaxien mit balken
vorkommen hätte man vermuten können dass
auch die innere milchstraße dieses
merkmal aufweist
unsere beobachtung bestätigen nun diesen
verdacht und sie geben uns ganz neue
chancen die natur des organisations
mechanismus und die energiezufuhr
aufzuklären damit können wir dieses
phänomen nun erstmals genauer erforschen
die chancen die linie emissionen nun
endlich aufklären zu können werden
dadurch natürlich deutlich größer und
bereits jetzt konnten die forscherinnen
und forscher spannende beobachtung
machen
je weiter man sich vom galaktischen
zentrum entfernt umso ähnlicher wird das
ionisierte gas den gas strömen der linie
galaxien im zentrum der milchstraße
dagegen verhält es sich anders
hier entspricht die spektrale signatur
des ionisierten gases er dem was man
auch für gas in einer stern
bildungsregion erwarten würde und genau
diese erkenntnis lässt das
forschungsteam daran zweifeln dass die
charakteristische linie emission alleine
durch die stern bildung zustande kommt
und damit durch diese vorgänge erklärt
werden kann
wie us fachleute halten deswegen andere
möglichkeiten für plausibler unter
anderem ziehen sie in erwägung dass die
sogenannten fermi blasen eine rolle
spielen genauer gesagt die heißen gase
die aus diesen mysteriösen strukturen
entweichen kurz zur erklärung die
sogenannten fermi blasen entstanden wohl
bei gewaltigen eruptionen im zentrum
unserer milchstraße und wurden erst vor
zehn jahren 2010 von us promi teams
aufgespürt sie bestehen aus
ausgestoßenen gasen und tragen etwa
30.000 lichtjahre aus dem zentrum der
milchstraße heraus diese sphärischen
strukturen sind im spektralbereich der
gammastrahlung zu beobachten und wurden
damals mit hilfe des fermi
weltraumteleskops der nasa auf
die gaspreise sind wirklich gigantisch
und außerdem wachsen sie immer weiter
bezüglich ihres ursprungs gibt es zwei
hypothesen zum einen könnten sie durch
eine krasse serie von sternen entstehung
in den zentralen regionen der
milchstraße entstanden sein
zum anderen könnten sie allerdings auch
durch die eruptionen des schwarzen lochs
in der mitte unserer heimatgalaxie ihren
ursprung haben so oder so der einstrom
heiße gase aus diesen beiden fermi
blasen könnte jedenfalls eine erklärung
für das zustandekommen der ionisierten
gase der milchstraße sein und natürlich
auch für charakteristische emissionen
anderer linie galaxien als fazit lässt
sich festhalten dass die neue us studie
also offenbart dass unsere heimat
galaxie zu der rätselhaften galaxien
klasse der linea galaxien gehört diese
erkenntnis könnte möglicherweise ein
wichtiger schritt hin zur lösung des
rätsels sein wie die ionisierten gase
dieser galaxien klasse wirklich zustande
kommt
den wissenschafterinnen wissenschaftlern
kommt dieses forschungsergebnis
natürlich sehr gelegen denn der nächste
linear kern einer galaxie legt somit
rund nur 25.000 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt somit lässt sie sich natürlich
in gewisser weise deutlich einfacher
erforschen als andere deutlich weiter
entfernte galaxien bei uns liegt das
ganze phänomen quasi vor der haustür
verrückt eigentlich dass wir so wenig
über die milchstraße wissen und das
obwohl sie unser heimatort ist erst vor
kurzem hatten australische
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler eine
ähnliche überraschende entdeckung
gemacht und auch diese änderte von jetzt
auf gleich unsere annahmen zu unserer
heimatgalaxie das forschungsteam hatte
nämlich festgestellt dass unsere
milchstraße sich extrem stark verbiegt
und diese wölbung rotiert überraschender
weise in einem rasanten tempo um das
galaxien zentrum unserer galaxie ähnelt
von der seite aus gesehen also einer s
förmigen welle der grund dafür ist bis
heute noch unerforscht doch mittlerweile
weiß man immerhin dass die verformung
alles andere als statisch ist die form
der s förmigen kurve bleibt zwar gleich
die zonen des auf- und abwärts gewölbten
galaxien randes aber wandern im laufe
der zeit sie ändern ihre position sie
kreisen quasi langsam um die galaxie
herum
die analyse des italienischen
forschungsteams vor einigen monaten
enthüllte somit also eine weitere
sensationelle
überraschung die wölbung rotiert sehr
schnell und das macht klar dass weder
dunkler materie im halo noch das
intergalaktische magnetfeld die ursache
für die verformung sein können denn nach
ansicht der fachleute müsste sich die
wölbung der sehr viel langsamer bewegen
bleibt also nur noch eine ursache übrig
die die verformung unserer galaxie
hervorrufen kann höchstwahrscheinlich
handelt es sich also um eine
zwerggalaxien die sich im nahen umfeld
der milchstraße befindet und ja immer
wieder nahe kommt deren schwerkraft
wirkung führt also zu der neu entdeckten
verformung konkret haben die fachleute
dieser guitar ios zwerggalaxien verdacht
sie ist etwa 70.000 lichtjahre entfernt
und ihre bahn offenbart dass sie im
laufe ihrer geschichte immer wieder mal
in den außenbereich unserer galaxie
eingedrungen ist vermutlich wird in den
kommenden 100 millionen jahren eine
weitere passage anstehen spektakuläre
entdeckung milchstraße hat seltsame form
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen kanal pixum science in
future bis dann bleibt dran